what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and today we have some
awesome deadpool 3 news deadpool in the
mcu we have news about the director
about the screenwriters and we're going
to be talking about what to expect from
the third deadpool film will it be rated
r and will he be making an mcu debut
before
deadpool 3 possibly in multiverse of
madness we're gonna break all that down
in this video but of course if you're
new be sure to subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest mcu news
let's break it down now there are a ton
of upcoming marvel movies that fans are
just super excited about doctor strange
and the multiverse of madness which is
going to include in some shape or form
x-men then we have an actual x-men movie
or mutants movie coming up at some point
in time and then of course the fantastic
four is supposed to be here within the
next couple of years and then of course
we have huge movies like thor love and
thunder but amongst all of these huge
massive movies coming out in the mcu one
of the movies that fans are most excited
about is the third deadpool film now
fans would have been excited about a
third deadpool film alone even if it was
still at fox but now deadpool is in the
mcu and now deadpool could have possibly
gotten the best director it could have
for deadpool 3. yesterday it was
revealed by the hollywood reporter that
deadpool 3 now has a director and that
director is sean levy if you are not
familiar with sean levy he just directed
the movie free guy with ryan reynolds
and taika watiti and it was hilarious
and an extremely great movie he also
recently directed with ryan reynolds the
atom project that recently came out on
netflix yesterday i watched it yesterday
and it is fantastic as well that movie
is kind of like a guardians of the
galaxy meets deadpool meets star wars
and i can say with confidence that after
watching free guy many many times and
the atom project last night sean levy is
going to do an absolutely incredible job
directing deadpool 3. he's just recently
worked with ryan reynolds on these last
two movies so the chemistry is obviously
really really good there and it looks
like they've just decided to keep the
ball rolling right into deadpool 3. now
if you watched free guy and i hope you
did because it's amazing there was
actually quite a bit of marvel in the
movie specifically towards the end we
had captain america shield we had a hulk
hand we had a lightsaber which isn't
marvel but star wars and chris evans
even made a tiny little cameo sean levy
has expressed before how much of a huge
marvel fan he is and specifically a huge
deadpool fan so no doubt over the past
few years while they were doing these
movies free guy and the atom project
ryan reynolds and sean talked about
deadpool and what they could make
together and yesterday ryan reynolds
even took to twitter to react to the
news that sean levy would be directing
deadpool 3. in a twitter post yesterday
he tweeted the third film in my sean
levi trilogy will be a tad more stabby
and then he put a picture that had the
three characters he's played with sean
levy so far on the right is guy from
free guy in the middle is adam from the
atom project and of course we all know
who is on the left deadpool so this
tweet even further confirms that sean
levi is going to be directing deadpool 3
and ryan reynolds is very excited about
it now we also do have a little bit more
news about the direction the script is
going it appears that the first draft of
the script is done about a year ago it
was announced that the maulanos sisters
were going to be writing the script for
deadpool 3 and they did along with ryan
reynolds of course but the hollywood
reporter stated that the molino sisters
finished the first draft of the film
however now rhett reese and paul wernick
are now writing the second draft of the
script and doing the screenplay and this
is also fantastic news because they
wrote the scripts for the first two
deadpool films so if we have a lot of
people out there worried that now that
deadpool is over at disney and not over
at fox if you're worried that he's going
to be changing a lot do not be worried
about that we have the same writers plus
ryan reynolds said he wanted to be a lot
more hands-on for deadpool 3 as far as
the script is concerned and direction is
concerned and now we have an amazing
director who has great chemistry with
ryan reynolds already and is a huge
deadpool fan you do not have to worry
about deadpool changing it sounds like
they're definitely sticking true to the
character and i trust ryan reynolds i
think even if they got a completely new
team marvel studios in disney made them
get an entire new staff ryan reynolds
would still stick true to who deadpool
was and let's be honest deadpool in the
mcu is kind of just ryan reynolds we
kind of associate them as one person
let's be honest so even if it was just
ryan reynolds coming back i'm sure it
would still be a great deadpool film but
we have an amazing cast and crew right
now and right now there are kind of two
important questions that we really need
to ask and we should note that ryan
reynolds did say that he would be making
a deadpool 3 announcement soon now he
didn't really make this announcement the
other day he came out and said that he
wanted sean levy to direct deadpool 3
and then yesterday the hollywood
reporter came out and they reported on
it but he didn't say anything and marvel
studios didn't say anything so perhaps
we'll be getting an official deadpool 3
announcement from ryan reynolds and
marvel studios relatively soon in an
interview not too long ago marvel
studios president kevin feige did say
that they did have a release date down
for deadpool 3 already so perhaps that
release date is going to be announced
relatively soon now as far as those two
important questions are concerned the
first one that we have to ask is will
deadpool be rated are still even though
it's in the mcu and over at disney well
first things first let's not forget what
former ceo bob iger said about deadpool
in the mcu now he said deadpool can
remain rated r he didn't say deadpool
could be rated r or we'll see about it
he said it's going to remain rated r
which is a great sign now he's no longer
the ceo bob chapeck is but you would
like to assume that they kind of have
the same thought process after all
deadpool and deadpool 2 are two of the
biggest grossing rated r movies of all
time record-breaking rated r movies and
fans love them it would be unwise to
change deadpool to a pg-13 movie but
this is actually coming right around the
time that all of the netflix marvel
shows are about to be released on disney
plus and these are definitely more
mature now disney plus is making some
adjustments to their parental controls
on the streaming service and this is
also a very good sign that deadpool can
remain rated r and not to mention marvel
is getting a little bit more risky we
did in fact have our first sex scene in
the eternals it wasn't much but hey it's
there and that just shows you that
really what marvel is going for is good
filmmaking and i don't think you can do
a deadpool movie if it's not rated r and
i think marvel and disney knows this but
the second biggest question we of course
have is will deadpool actually make his
mcu appearance before deadpool 3 and i
think the answer to this of course is
yes i think deadpool is going to be
introduced to the mcu in multiverse of
madness with all of these crazy
different rumors going around about all
of these different cameos that could
happen in doctor strange 2. i think one
that makes the most sense is deadpool
deadpool can enter the mcu this way
going from the fox universe to the mcu
whether that's just in a normal scene
throughout the movie a post-credits
scene whatever it may be i think that
it's the perfect opportunity and the
timing works out as well it looks like
we'll be getting deadpool 3 in the next
couple of years so showing the fans in
the audience that hey he's in the mcu
now to kind of avoid a bit of confusion
would be a smart idea but let me know
what you think about this in the
comments down below and let me know how
excited you are to finally be able to
see deadpool in the mcu let me know down
below don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest marvel news for live
updates you can always follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof